Ben Grimm vous savez la chose dans les
Quatre Fantastiques et ben est-ce que
vous savez que les hommes de Pierre ça
existe vraiment ils sont atteints de
fibrodysplasie aussi chiante progressive
qui est une maladie qui a la
particularité de transformer les muscles
en os la mutation commence vers l'âge de
2 ans par la nuque et les épaules puis
elle évolue par pousser vers le bas du
corps petit à petit tous les muscles
deviennent très durs la maladie de
l'homme de pierre comme on l'appelle est
extrêmement rare et elle touche une
personne sur deux millions elle est très
handicapante parce qu'elle touche aussi
les tendons et finit par limiter les
mouvements et inexistent actuellement
aucun traitement pour la soigner
attention la fibre au dysplasie aussi
chiante progressive ne donne pas
l'apparence extérieure de bengrim là ça
ressemble plus à une maladie qui couvre
le corps de tumeur bénigne la
neurofibromatose de type 1 ou maladie de
reclingha